all right let's hear the pitch what do  you got basically it's pirates in space  oh we remake wall-e all the robots are  humans now and all the humans are robots  you know what i like you i like your  idea they're fighting the lord commander  from jupiter oh that's good it'll be a  little pricey getting the rights from  disney of course i'll give you a hundred  million dollars oh my god thank you  thank you thank you good doing business  with you take the money oh i don't have  a pitch i'm the uber eats you ordered a  calzone and uh calamari i like you i  like this guy you want to show see me at  my office i'll give you a tv show i got  them i'm netflix baby  [Music]  uh mr netflix yep there's about 35  people on the line uh waiting to talk to  you uh apparently you gave them shows  idiot we'll cancel after season one  except too hot to handle give them a  billion dollars  [Music]